- [Narrator] A while back,
I was teaching physics in California.
I got to class and I
was all like, hey class,
you wanna hear a physics joke?
Yeah, okay, totally.
Does light hold mass?
I don't know, does it?
No, it's not even Catholic.
Oh man.
Shoulda went to the beach today.
Dude, really?
Totally lame.
But wait, doesn't light really have mass?
It should.
It's got momentum so it's gotta have mass.
It has momentum so it must have mass.
Whoa, hey!
Everyone just calm the heck down.
You see, the worst part of all this
wasn't that my joke bombed,
it was that I actually managed
to confuse people by telling it.
My students had read
that light has momentum
and they were right, light
really does have momentum.
But then I come to class and I'm all like,
hey, guess what, light has no mass.
Now my students are
thinking to themselves,
dude, but P equals MV.
In other words, if momentum
equals mass times velocity,
how could light, which has
no mass, ever have momentum?
Well, I had to break it to my students
that P equals MV
isn't really accurate
for things that travel
close to the speed of light.
For things going that fast,
you have to use special relativity.
I don't wanna waste a lot of time
talking about special
relativity in this video
so you're just gonna have
to take my word for it
that the rules of special
relativity allow for a loophole.
This loophole provides a
way for massless objects
to have momentum.
Alright, so the bad news
is that we cannot use
P equals MV to find the
momentum of a photon.
The good news is that the
formula for the momentum
of a photon is simple,
the momentum of a photon
equals H over lambda.
H is Planck's constant,
6.626 times 10 to the
negative 34 joule-seconds.
Lambda is the wavelength
of the light in meters.
Be careful, don't use nanometers,
you have to convert to meters.
The momentum of a single photon
is gonna be extremely small,
that's why it doesn't feel
like we're getting pushed on
very much when light shines
on us, but theoretically,
if you had a big enough
solar sail, the light
bouncing off of that solar
sail could propel it forward
due to the impulse imparted
by the momentum of the light.
Okay, so very long story short,
you should never ever use P equals MV
to find the momentum of a photon.
To find the momentum of a photon,
you should always use
momentum equals H over lambda.
(ambient techno music)